how do you know this lovely lady yes
friends
that is cute what are you doing Miss
isn't it funny when you're a pretty girl
you just be in marketing my wife was in
marketing for years she didn't do I'm
not saying you're not smart I'm not
saying you're not talented I'm saying
you didn't get a job based on marriage
but if you're hot you could be the
dumbest to ever walked on the face of
the earth and the White House would be
like you want a job
I'll give you the nuclear codes what do
you want to do all right well that's
cool marketing so what do you do for
marketing you ain't saying nothing just
now you know that your whole job is
pitches for events hey you guys want to
have a party are you gonna be there yeah
yeah
I'm your job is about as believable as
his friendship
[Laughter]
[Applause]